Let's do some more
percentage problems.
Let's say that I start
this year in my stock
portfolio with $95.00.
And I say that my portfolio
grows by, let's say, 15%.
How much do I have now?
OK.
I think you might be able to
figure this out on your own,
but of course we'll do some
example problems, just in case
it's a little confusing.
So I'm starting with $95.00,
and I'll get rid of
the dollar sign.
We know we're working
with dollars.
95 dollars, right?
And I'm going to earn, or I'm
going to grow just because
I was an excellent stock
investor, that 95 dollars
is going to grow by 15%.
So to that 95 dollars, I'm
going to add another 15% of 95.
So we know we write 15% as a
decimal, as 0.15, so 95 plus
0.15 of 95, so this is
times 95-- that dot
is just a times sign.
It's not a decimal, it's a
times, it's a little higher
than a decimal-- So 95 plus
0.15 times 95 is what
we have now, right?
Because we started with 95
dollars, and then we made
another 15% times what
we started with.
Hopefully that make sense.
Another way to say it, the 95
dollars has grown by 15%.
So let's just work this out.
This is the same thing as 95
plus-- what's 0.15 times 95?
Let's see.
So let me do this, hopefully
I'll have enough space here.
95 times 0.15-- I don't
want to run out of space.
Actually, let me do it up here,
I think I'm about to run out
of space-- 95 times 0.15.
5 times 5 is 25, 9 times 5 is
45 plus 2 is 47, 1 times 95 is
95, bring down the 5,
12, carry the 1, 15.
And how many decimals
do we have?
1, 2.
15.25.
Actually, is that right?
I think I made a mistake here.
See 5 times 5 is 25.
5 times 9 is 45, plus 2 is 47.
And we bring the 0 here, it's
95, 1 times 5, 1 times 9, then
we add 5 plus 0 is 5,
7 plus 5 is 12-- oh.
See?
I made a mistake.
It's 14.25, not 15.25.
So I'll ask you an
interesting question?
How did I know that
15.25 was a mistake?
Well, I did a reality check.
I said, well, I know in my head
that 15% of 100 is 15, so if
15% of 100 is 15, how can
15% of 95 be more than 15?
I think that might
have made sense.
The bottom line is 95
is less than 100.
So 15% of 95 had to be less
than 15, so I knew my
answer of 15.25 was wrong.
And so it turns out that I
actually made an addition
error, and the answer is 14.25.
So the answer is going to be 95
plus 15% of 95, which is the
same thing as 95 plus 14.25,
well, that equals what?
109.25.
Notice how easy I made
this for you to read,
especially this 2 here.
109.25.
So if I start off with $95.00
and my portfolio grows-- or the
amount of money I have-- grows
by 15%, I'll end
up with $109.25.
Let's do another problem.
Let's say I start off with some
amount of money, and after a
year, let's says my portfolio
grows 25%, and after growing
25%, I now have $100.
How much did I originally have?
Notice I'm not saying that
the $100 is growing by 25%.
I'm saying that I start with
some amount of money, it grows
by 25%, and I end up with
$100 after it grew by 25%.
To solve this one, we
might have to break out
a little bit of algebra.
So let x equal what
I start with.
So just like the last problem,
I start with x and it grows by
25%, so x plus 25% of x is
equal to 100, and we know this
25% of x we can just rewrite as
x plus 0.25 of x is equal to
100, and now actually we have a
level-- actually this might be
level 3 system, level 3 linear
equation-- but the bottom
line, we can just add the
coefficients on the x.
x is the same thing
as 1x, right?
So 1x plus 0.25x, well that's
just the same thing as 1 plus
0.25, plus x-- we're just doing
the distributive property
in reverse-- equals 100.
And what's 1 plus 0.25?
That's easy, it's 1.25.
So we say 1.25x
is equal to 100.
Not too hard.
And after you do a lot of these
problems, you're going to
intuitively say, oh, if some
number grows by 25%, and it
becomes 100, that means that
1.25 times that number
is equal to 100.
And if this doesn't make sense,
sit and think about it a little
bit, maybe rewatch the video,
and hopefully it'll, over time,
start to make a lot
of sense to you.
This type of math is
very very useful.
I actually work at a hedge
fund, and I'm doing
this type of math in my
head day and night.
So 1.25 times x is equal
to 100, so x would equal
100 divided by 1.25.
I just realized you
probably don't know
what a hedge fund is.
I invest in stocks
for a living.
Anyway, back to the math.
So x is equal to 100
divided by 1.25.
So let me make some space
here, just because I
used up too much space.
Let me get rid of my
little let x statement.
Actually I think we know
what x is and we know
how we got to there.
If you forgot how we got
there, you can I guess
rewatch the video.
Let's see.
Let me make the pen thin
again, and go back to
the orange color, OK.
X equals 100 divided by 1.25,
so we say 1.25 goes into
100.00-- I'm going to add a
couple of 0's, I don't know how
many I'm going to need,
probably added too many-- if I
move this decimal over two to
the right, I need to move this
one over two to the right.
And I say how many times does
100 go into 100-- how many
times does 125 go into 100?
None.
How many times does
it go into 1000?
It goes into it eight times.
I happen to know that in my
head, but you could do trial
and error and think about it.
8 times-- if you want to think
about it, 8 times 100 is
800, and then 8 times 25 is
200, so it becomes 1000.
You could work out if you like,
but I think I'm running out of
time, so I'm going
to do this fast.
8 times 125 is 1000.
Remember this thing isn't here.
1000, so 1000 minus 1000 is 0,
so you can bring down the 0.
125 goes into 0 zero times,
and we just keep getting 0's.
This is just a decimal
division problem.
So it turns out that if your
portfolio grew by 25% and
you ended up with $100.00
you started with $80.00.
And that makes sense, because
25% is roughly 1/4, right?
So if I started with $80.00 and
I grow by 1/4, that means I
grew by $20, because
25% of 80 is 20.
So if I start with 80
and I grow by 20,
that gets me to 100.
Makes sense.
So remember, all you have to
say is, well, some number times
1.25-- because I'm growing
it by 25%-- is equal to 100.
Don't worry, if you're still
confused, I'm going to add at
least one more presentation
on a couple of more
examples like this.